Cara Delevingne and Ashley Benson have
called it quits after being in a
relationship for nearly two years
multiple media outlets have reported the
couple parted ways in early April the
couple was seemingly quarantine together
after production shut down on cars
Amazon Prime series carnival row in
March cara posted this tik-tok to her
Instagram
so are we cool like are we in agreement
there is Cara with Ashley recreating a
classic moment from Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
abcdefg actually know what the heck is
ABCDE of Jamie it's just a phrase I like
to use that means not a real frame the
conversation is over if you say ABCD efg
in December the British actress
surprised Ashley for her birthday with
not only a trip to Morocco
happy birthday Ashley but also a
personalized message from the Olsen
twins I hope this year is one of the
best ones yet
magical and can't wait to meet you soon
in August 28th teen rumors swirled that
the actresses were more than friends
after meeting on the set of the movie
her smell but they didn't officially
confirm the relationship until June 2019
I also have a very another special woman
in this room to thank while accepting
The Trevor Project Hero Award Cara gave
a loving shout-out to Ashley in her
speech she's one of the people that
helped me enough myself when I needed it
most
and I really needed it she showed me
what real love is and show me how to
accept it which was a lot harder than
they thought
[Music]